good morning hickets tuesday i am
hopefully emerging from a lengthy bout
with the flu it's not kovid it's the flu
such an old-school virus i feel like i'm
in the 1990s with my acid wash jeans and
my cassette tapes and my influenza in
other news the fault in our stars was
first published 10 years ago yesterday i
still don't know how to make sense of
being the author of that book except to
say that i am extremely grateful that it
is still in print and still finding new
readers but yeah 10 years it occurs to
me perhaps because i am sick that i
spent my first three books trying to
understand the consequences of
misimagining one another and my most
recent three books trying to understand
the consequences of misimagining what
happens to us like my first three books
were about failing to imagine other
people as full persons seeing them
simplistically as more or less than
human and this was an interesting theme
to me partly because when i was a
teenager i often failed to imagine other
people complexly but also because i saw
it a lot in the culture i saw us
dehumanizing people and also heroizing
or romanticizing individuals and often
acting as if romanticizing someone was
generous or benevolent when in fact it
can be really destructive but after
writing paper towns i felt like i'd
explored that as fully as i could like
the whole plot hinges upon the narrator
realizing as he puts it that margot was
not a miracle she was not an adventurer
she was not a fine and precious thing
she was a girl i felt like i'd said what
i wanted to say as clearly as i knew how
to say it and so for a while i was a
writer without a theme which meant a lot
of like aimless wandering like i wrote
about 60 000 words of two different
novels and they just never worked they
weren't bad exactly they just didn't
have a reason to be at its best language
gives form and sense to the formless and
senseless and these stories weren't
doing that but i eventually found a
theme by returning to something that i
started writing way back in 2000 the
theme was how do we make sense of the
stuff that happens to us the stuff that
we don't control and what are the
consequences of misimagining that stuff
like as susan sontag points out in
illness as metaphor it was commonly
believed as late as the 1970s that
cancer was caused by not being loved
enough or else by like immoral behavior
the same is true for cholera and
epilepsy and disease is still often
constructed as part of some divine
retribution scheme like i remember as a
kid people on tv saying that hiv was
sent by god to punish gay people these
ways of imagining illness are
tremendously harmful because they create
a kind of double horror not only does
the person who's sick suffer from the
illness itself they may also suffer from
a social order that marginalizes or
dehumanizes them for being ill really
even metaphors that seem benign that
like illness is a battle to be one or a
mountain to be climbed can complicate
the experience of that illness because
what if you don't climb the mountain
it's not your fault my dad had cancer
twice when i was a kid and so i'd seen
some of this stuff up close the way
people keep their distance from you even
though you're not contagious the way
they construct stories about why your
dad got cancer to reassure themselves
that their dad won't like oh he had a
lot of stress in his life or oh he did
this or didn't do that the fault always
in the self never in the stars also i
really dislike the convention of the
genre where sick people get sick so that
healthy people can learn lessons it just
that drives me bonkers and so i wanted
to write a book with no healthy kids in
it and i've continued that theme since
writing about what happens when we
misunderstand mental illness and turtles
all the way down and writing about
historical responses to disease
especially infectious disease in the
anthropocene reviewed now of course
there are other themes in those books
turtles is about what we talk about when
we talk about free will the anthropocene
reviewed is about like what's even the
point oh wait i just had a thought maybe
i'm always writing about how we can make
meaning in our lives without minimizing
or denying the meaning in other people's
lives although maybe not i don't know i
do have a slight fever so don't take
anything i'm saying too seriously
regardless thank you for keeping hazel
and gus around all these years it means
a lot to me hank i'll see you on friday